hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today's
question comes from one of my YouTube
viewers who asked about getting a
college degree and you wrote insane what
college degree do you think is essential
for anyone to have when certain
Enterprise if any so this is always a
tough question should I go to college or
not and if you're if you're gonna get a
college degree I would probably suggest
something in business commerce finance
just so that you understand how that
world works especially if you're coming
from a different background so if you're
a scientist or someone from the arts and
you've never done anything in business
before it could help you a lot to get a
degree in business just to understand
that world and don't be able to figure
it out through textbooks it's not the
necessarily the best learning experience
but you're gonna learn a lot more than
if you kind of stuck to the science and
arts program about how to run a business
one thing I found really helpful about
my university education so I had a
bachelor's degree from University of
Toronto
I majored in finance commerce and
economics and the education side for
running the business was not fantastic I
was already running my company at the
time and I found that learning a lot
more through hands-on experience than I
did from the textbooks in the class and
you'll find that in general you'll get
the best learning experience from
actually hands-on training and going
after what you're interested in I don't
want to suggest not going to get an
education
because it can also provide a great
back-up plan
you know not everybody is meant to be an
entrepreneur and if it doesn't work out
you want to have something that you can
fall back on and easily be able to go
out and get a job because if you don't
have a job and don't have an education
it's a lot harder to get those jobs so
it is a good backup plan and you can
also make some good connections so
you're meeting with people who might
have similar mindsets to you my first
two business partners were at the same
university that I was at
we will form our company out of the
University so meeting meeting them and
being able to start the company was
extremely helpful and that happened
through the university so you know if we
weren't all at the University would it
have happened you know maybe maybe not
but that was a useful thing as well so
you can get connections and if you ever
end up selling to big business a lot of
the guys who are in your class are gonna
go get jobs and they could be potential
leads into sales so you can make with
your company down the line so I think
the best experience you're gonna get is
the hands-on I've cut my teeth on
entrepreneurship really early with my
own little businesses and through
programs like Junior Achievement where
they make you start a business in
elementary school and that stuff was was
awesome so I still think I'm gonna get
the most from your hands-on experience
but I don't want to say don't go to
school because it's a great back-up plan
if you're not from a business background
you'll be able to get some some good
skills that'll teach you the the
fundamental basics about running the
business and you can also make some
great connections that can help you
learn more about yourself and also help
you down down the road as you do grow
your business so hopefully that helps
some tough decisions for you to make if
you guys liked the video please give it
a thumbs up below it's what makes me
want to do more things for you guys and
if you have a question about this video
or you have a different question about
your business feel free to leave it in
the comments below and I will make a
video reply for you so thank you and
we'll see you on the next episode
you